all right so welcome back to 8701
so we have all ingredients now to
prepare
fireman rules for qed so that's the
toolkit we need in order to make
calculations to calculate scattering
processes
in the case and we have already seen
fileman rules for our toy theory
again now the situation is a little bit
more complicated because we can consider
the spin of particles in addition
to their energy and momenta the rules
sequence of things are very much the
same there is however a few caveats to
keep in mind and i'll point out
okay so the very first thing is to be
very clear in
our notation so this is an arbitrary
or generic qed farming diagram we have
only
pointed out the incoming and the
outgoing
so there's internal lines which i didn't
mention here
important to note the momentum momentum
and the directions the directions are
arbitrary we just have to be clear on
them and then
treat them consistently right so this is
not different in our previous discussion
then here comes the difference um
our external lines are either electron
positrons or photons
right you can fermions and photons
charged fermions and photons so we
discussed how the solutions look like
our spinos u
and v and for outgoing for outgoing
electrons for outgoing particles we have
this adjunct vector here which is given
by
u dagger gamma zero and similarly for
the incoming anti-particle
v dagger gamma zero for the photon we
have the polarization vectors
for incoming and outgoing photons
all right then we have a vertex vector
here now g
zero or ge is a
constant um and a dimensionless property
but we do have to have a gamma gamma mu
here
um as part of our vertex factor
for the propagator or internal lines we
have a difference between electrons
positrons and photons and that comes
from the fact
that electrons impose it from the mass
of particles
so we have vertex vectors which
know have you know this one over q
square behavior or one over excuse me
minus m square behavior
so here you can already see that there's
going to be a complication later when we
evaluate
or integrate our momentum simply uh the
same discussion had before and we
already know how to solve this problem
uh of infinities by renormalizing by
having a cut off and we
normalizing them excellent
so the next steps end is very much the
same uh there's no change
we have to make sure that there's energy
and momentum conservation and reinforces
introducing delta functions uh we have
to integrate over each and every
internal momenta and each
in each internal line
gets one of those integration factors
and then after we integrate we have to
we are left with the delta function and
we have to cancel that delta function
all right in our toy experiment the
order of things didn't matter
everything we had in there was scala's
numbers
right here we do have a little bit more
complicated problems so
there's an importance in the order of
which we execute things
so what we're going to do is you know
form firmware learn lines you just
follow a fermion as we go from the left
to the right
and you will find things which are
always of the form
an adjoint spinner a four cross four
times four matrix
and a spino and the result of this is
going to be a number
all right great there is one additional
complication
is accounting for duplications and
making sure that the sign is
and i'm just mentioning this here this
will become more clear
as we walk through examples so there's
an anti-semitration going on
where we have to introduce a minus sign
between the diagrams
between different diagrams that differ
only by the interchange or the exchange
of two incoming
or two outgoing electrons or positrons
and or the incoming electron with an
outgoing positron
so you have a diagram which is exactly
the same
but you know the two incoming electrons
are interchanged you have to add those
two diagrams
you know you have to add all matrix
elements together
before we calculate an amplitude but you
have to introduce a minus sign when you
change
those two particles so with that we have
we can now
just basically calculate whatever qd
process we want
all the tools are already here and what
we want to do now next in the next video
also in the in the recitation and
homework
is to go through a few examples to get a
little practice with this
there's a number of tricks um which will
become handy and i explain those in a
separate video
they're just mathematical tricks which
allow us to quickly evaluate
the multiplication of spinos and matrix
elements and so on
all right that's it for this video
um again there's going to be another two
or three videos which deal with
actually evaluating or calculating
matrix elements